Tron Aries is about to go into filming
the long awaited sequel to Tron
legacy but what do we know about the
project what have a few insiders
exclusively told me about the project
and we have to ask the big question will
this movie be worth watching welcome to
citre your SciFi TV and Movie
Channel it's fair to say that Tron
legacy was not a massively over
overwhelming success it was okay it was
actually quite good in places but when
you compare it to the original Tron
which is really in many ways an iconic
sci-fi movie it didn't quite meet up to
the original let's say that so will this
new project Tron Aries be better first
of all there is not a lot officially out
there about Tron Aries and actually what
the film is going to be about even
though it does go into production
actually starts filming very very
shortly I'm told within weeks it's going
to actually be on the same stage filming
what we do know is that this is going to
be slightly different to Tron Ascension
which was actually the planned sequel to
Tron legacy so when they did Tron legacy
they were hoping for a massive hit and
they did plan an immediate sequel it was
not the massive hit and the sequel
quietly went into development hell we
now have this new project which
officially is called Tron 3 but is the
working title of Tron Aries and I'm
being told that actually will be the
title we know that Jared letto is
starring as Aries and is believed and I
can actually tell you that sources
closest have been able to confirm to me
that the original storyline is still the
basic premise plot of the movie is that
Aries is a sensient program who escapes
into the human world most of this movie
will be far more based around actual
reality in the real world rather than on
the grid there is obviously a big
question about whether Jeff Bridges and
Bruce Brock lner will actually return
for this but I'm going to tease you on
that just a little bit and first of all
I'm going to talk about the actual
project so for one the Stars Jared letto
now it's fair to say Jared letto is an
unusual f but he is actually a very good
actor I've actually liked him in most
things I've seen him I even liked him as
the Joker which I know is controversial
but I quite liked him I'm not always
sure he puts 100% into every project he
does I think there are some films and
this is only my opinion but I think
there are some films that he thinks are
more important than others I am actually
thinking about morbius I don't think
that was his best performance and I
wonder maybe it was because he didn't
take it as seriously as he would other
projects and I do wonder whether that
might be a similar problem for Tron I
would also point out that the character
that Jared letto here is playing a
sensient program that escapes into the
real world that's been done so let's see
if they can do something a little bit
different and let's hope he actually
brings his a game to the project fingers
crossed I'm hoping they have something
in there that's original because I
cannot help but feel that this movie has
been done before and I'm even thinking
about sort of agent Smith and um The
Matrix sequels when you know agent Smith
downloaded himself into a human being
and started wreaking havoc or even lawn
mower man which was a very again similar
sort of storyline I know studios are
desperate to do the next big AI project
because it is so in our culture at the
moment it is so in the people's General
Consciousness but to me this is a story
story line that I'm a little bit
disappointed by I'm just hoping that
they're doing something different with
it and the director is very very
important on that and does he set the
correct tone does he actually do this in
an original way if you're enjoying the
video don't forget to like subscribe and
hit that Bell notification so you miss
none of our new videos and most
importantly leave a comment it's a
community after all we want to know what
you think too I can actually also tell
you about two other big actors that are
going to be in this project they're
going to have the leading roles one
Greta Lee is going to be the main
heroine but also now Evan Pinter has
signed on I'm being told that his
character is a little bit of an
anti-hero that he is the one that is
sort of tricked um by Aries and to let
in Aries out into the real world gets
Aries his human body Etc and that even
though he's not necessarily a villain
he's a slightly weaker character that
gets used by Aries and
eventually turns on him so the cast on
the whole is interesting they have some
pretty heavyweight actors here
remembering that Evan Peters has just on
a Golden Globe for his um portrayal as
um Dharma in that series that miniseries
he did where he was genuinely terrifying
and this is an actor as well that don't
forget was seriously likable in the
X-Men movies is Quicks Sila to be honest
he was one of the best things about
those movies so they have a very
adaptable actor in EV Peters they have
an upcoming Star in Greta Lee and they
have Jared letto who regardless of what
you think about him you might be crazy
they have a director that I think can do
it and they have a script that has been
in development for nearly a decade so
what can go wrong I would argue almost
all of those things I've just said are a
problem except for Evan Peters and Greta
Lee I think those two are safe I think
almost everything else about this
project is potentially a problem
a script that has been development for
nearly a decade is a massive red flags
for me also the fact that this is
basically just an evolution of the same
project that they planned following Tron
legacy is a massive red flag for me how
many times have we seen this before if
the script was really good enough it
wouldn't go through multiple rewrites it
wouldn't sit in development hell for 10
years all right Tron legacy wasn't the
massive hit that they were hoping for
but it was good enough that they could
would have got a sequel off the back of
it if they really wanted to they didn't
they have a director here who has a
mixed bag of projects as far as I can
tell and nothing really that scream
sci-fi but let's go through it quickly
Maleficent Mistress of evil in 2019
doomsday pouch the Caribbean sales's
Revenge Max Manis man of war Bandidas
Marco Polo and something called contiki
which I didn't see so a director that
has a bit of a mixed bag of projects in
his um Arenal that even though I say he
can do something quite Arty with it I
think he's a very visual director but
he's never really done anything science
fiction he has done projects that even
though they might be visually very
interesting have not particularly had a
lot of substance I would argue and I'm
not sure that this is the right person
to bring back a major franchise if
that's what they're trying to do
Jared letto is also a massive concern
for me and as I said I question whether
he would really bring his aame to a
project like this calling this Aries
though is interesting because if you
don't know Aries is the Greek God of War
the son of Zeus and Heron Aries was a
bloodthirsty violent God but he was also
seen as a bit of a joke figure by the
Greek who was regularly tricked and
defeated let's not forget that Aries was
basically tricked Red by his sister into
supporting the Trojans during the Trojan
War and we know how that ended this is a
complex character and if the Aries
character in this movie reflects some of
that mythology it could actually make
for quite an interesting character but
will they do that will they create a
nuanced character that really respects
the mythology or will they do what other
films have done and they will have the
god of war and really go no deep ER than
the fact that he loves a bit of War I
suspect that is more likely what we're
going to get and again that will also be
a massive
shame and no I hadn't forgotten will
Bruce Brock sletner and Jeff Bridges
return for Tron 3 this question has been
asked a lot and every time basically
anybody talks about this project the
question is asked again I can tell you
that actually neither will be massively
involved in the next movie but both will
be a little bit I'm actually been told
that the plan at the moment is that
there'll be a digital version of a
younger Jeff Bridges and a younger Bruce
Brock sletner basically voiced by both
and um that they'll be heavily created
using AI Bruce BR let know and Jeff
Bridges will be paid handsomely I'm sure
for that now that the New Deal is in
place with the um actor's guilds and
that those characters will only appear
in the grid parts of this movie but as I
said the bulk of the movie will actually
be based in the real world so we can
expect those parts to be fleeting and
quite limited but it will be interesting
to see those characters the way I see it
really is that as Aries escapes the grid
it'll be Bruce Brock slers and Jeff
bridges' characters they're trying to
stop it and trying to prevent it um they
obviously fail because Aries does escape
and I can see that that is where those
characters will appear and it'll be
probably
seconds so do I think Tron 3 is going to
be a project we should all rush out and
see well it's too early to really be
definitive all I will say is I've got my
concerns but get into the comments and
tell me what you think everything I've
told you about this project do you have
any alarm bells ringing or do you think
no give it a chance let's see what comes
out and at the end of the day we're
going to be teased with a lot of little
Clips Etc and a lot more information
over the next six months let's give it
an opportunity I always say give
everything a chance until you've seen it
even if there are red flags sometimes
all these red flags they come true and
we end up here with a project that we go
yeah I bloody knew it but sometimes
these things they're greater than the
some of their parts it could turn out
actually that this director is a Sci-Fi
genius it could turn out that gered
letto is really into this and really
brings his a game which if he does he
will be a brilliant villain it could be
that the script after 10 years of
development comes out polished and
beautiful all of these things could just
click together that's a possibility but
what do you actually think get to the
comments and tell me if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us out and you'll never miss any of our
new videos also you can go to
patreon.com citre where most of our new
videos do Premiere first and you get to
see them without the adverts
finally you can go to c.co do.uk where I
do articles based on a lot of our videos
and I try to add a little bit more
information for you to digest so go
check that out too as always please stay
safe and I'll see you next
[Music]
time